In lesson 14, we examined ways we could analyze the relationship between two
numerical variables using scatter plots and Pearson's r. Remember that r is a
measure of the strength of their relationship, and looks at how x and y vary
together as opposed to how they each vary independently. We also noted that we
can describe linear data using a straight line drawn through the middle of the
data. In this lesson, we will discuss this straight line in more detail, and
explain why it's useful for describing linear relationships and making
predictions. This straight line has several names. One is the regression line.
Another more intuitive name is the line of best fit. We care about the line of
best fit, because it helps us describe the data for one thing. In other words,
we can describe the patterns shown by the data. This line makes it easier to
see the relationship between x and y. In this lesson, we'll only focus on
linear relationships. Meaning relationships that follow a linear trend in one
direction. Not only does the line help us visualize the data, but it helps us
make predictions. We can use the line to predict what the y value will be for a
particular x value. By knowing the equation, we can plug in this x value, say x
star, and find the corresponding y value, y star. Our predictions won't be
perfectly accurate, but we can often get a fairly good estimate for the value
of y.